but would you ever do something with
that i'll definitely do something with
her
um you know
well you know what i'll give you that
one gem i'll drop myself in at once
[Music]
all right lads it's matt from live bible
and i'm here with brighton's biggest
geezer
rd audi are you doing very good yes yes
i sat down as i'm good i'm good
you know you're a little bit fragile
today um just a little bit hungry
love that all right so just to basically
listen let's kick off right i'll try my
best right to summarize
the past couple of months for you
because it's been pretty crazy so
obviously all your videos um pretty much
hitting a million million views
and you obviously went on the body remix
and bodied it
and of course um the the remix and your
verse especially went viral on tick tock
and then yesterday you went to the brits
how mad has the last couple of months
been for you
it has been absolutely mental literally
non-stop i feel like i
don't get a chance to sit down and come
and see my mom as much as i can but yeah
flying up and down obviously a lot of
things
happen up in london so yeah literally
busy busy bee flying around everywhere
but
it comes at a job so is your mumsy um
keeping you on the ground
keeping you humble as much as she can
yeah as much as she can like i said
obviously i like to party and get lit
and whatnot and have a good time
well your number got leaked as well
which was pretty nuts for you your phone
went mad but
what happened there you know what it was
yeah at first i was mad enjoying it like
it was sick i got to interact with all
the fans like so i had some girls that
cried i had people from australia
facetiming me
and ireland germany a lot of people were
saying that oh like you're so you're so
cool for speaking to us and
actually answering and my thing was
about you listen to me every day or
whatever
i drop my music so i can give you like
one day in it
but it got to about one in the morning
and for some reason from there i went
men one of the fans actually told me
that like a famous american snapchatter
had put it on her story
oh man but from there it went like at
first it was kind of like every
every minute but yeah
[Music]
i don't actually live a lifestyle
that like a typical rapper or like celeb
i don't even want to call myself a
celebrity but
someone that is in a limelight would
live something like dude might do like
lavish and like all these
luxurious things and i don't bought no
jewelry no chains i still wear
tracksuits everywhere even when i go in
clubbing
point i had like a hundred thousand
followers on instagram
and eight thousand antiques so i brought
tick tock hated me you know anything i
just got slated it was all my comments
no idea they just
all my comments just because me getting
slated did it like no one reading it no
i was following it
we were trying to think literally yeah
but after that come out
i don't even know what happened a couple
days later my
yeah my manager just sent me like 20
links have you seen how many people are
making tick tocks and obviously i posted
on my one where i was in the studio
like when i actually made it and yeah
now i think there's like four hundred
thousand videos or something that i
always in my verse like
the most follow tick tock girl was done
one and
yeah it's literally gone i can't get
away from it but
i like the sound of my own voice so i
don't really mind
that's always good that's always good
when you go viral
you're talking about um you're getting
like loads of hate messages and stuff
like that or you know people basically
being negative
what was your response like do you ever
like ever get like the urge to like
message him back and be like shut up
there was there was you know what it is
i find all of them hilarious like
someone
was like it hates shagged harry potter
and i would literally piss him off
because i have my glasses on
in the video in it it's like right he's
not a guide
so anyone who's watched the sixth
amendment brighton music video
wanna know right where was that woman
going
oh you're sick you'll see everyone's
been saying this one bro
i don't know in it i literally have no
idea we were just saying look walk past
the camera
i'm gonna obviously look you up and down
yeah danny and whatever whatever no idea
i think
she walking platform what's it not in
three quarters trying to go to a homeboy
i don't even know about
zero idea one of your boys he got killed
online like
i think it was like the guy on the far
left in your bars
yeah cheeky bars and he was he was
looking he's moving a bit stiff
yeah yeah yeah that was
are you mad it was hilarious we were all
dying like he was literally
i think he was part of the reason why
that went more viral than what it did
literally like so many people were
talking and obviously the more
interaction of comments whatever you get
but obviously because i'm looking at the
camera i didn't know i was watching it
it's kind of like
he's looking at me through what i do and
i'm doing it like two seconds late and
offbeat it was
crazy you seen the state of her body if
i beat
[Music]
actually i don't give a [__] i have no
idea what the [__] just went on
kind of got him rather than dancing
confidence in it you're brave enough to
push something like that on a uk
i've got a little mini quiz i want to
run with you all right so what i've done
i've grabbed some comments from your
videos on youtube
and some from h's all right and i just
want you to guess
um who this per like the person who
commented is talking
it was for me or h yeah your h
looks like a grown version of boss baby
mocking it they
violated it it's got 13 000 likes
are you not taking the piss
but you don't know what it's about yet i
reckon it's about me i'm not lying i
reckon it's about me that's what my
money is at
it actually isn't about you it's
actually i mean that's that's pete for
donating but
yeah that's made me feel a little bit
better
[Laughter]
pickford really enjoying his free time
that one's going to be about me
i actually kind of see it just a little
bit i'd say it's about me
you are incorrect i'll shut it down yeah
yeah it's about each
this is the kind of lad that shoplifts a
50p energy drink
well i'm not even going to lie i have
teeth for a couple 50p energy
all right last minute switch and you
smashed it
so it says blank is the kind of guy
to rob you and then make you want to
give him a good goodbye kiss when he's
leaving that's a
weird comment you know what does that
even mean
i don't know whether to feel kind of
weird or it's a compliment or is it this
yeah it's just it's about me but i'd say
i'd say it's about me i think
yeah i'm saying 3 000 likes on that one
as well [__] people agreeing
the kind of guy to rob you and make you
want to also
i'll rob you yeah but you want to give
me a kiss before i leave
[Music]
yeah that's kind of mad
[Laughter]
that's a bit mad with regards to the
lyrics of the body remix
um you you know one of the lyrics is uh
i am wearing a johnny
right i actually do not let me do that
enough
if you don't know the girl and she's not
on contraception
or you don't know who she's been with or
where she's been or even like that to be
his [__] i don't know what to say to go
even the boy
you're a girl and the boy is saying he
don't want to wear one if you don't know
where he's been and you make up
contraception and you don't know who's
got what then
i don't condone unsafe how long i've
never actually just
beat and dashed like a random chick that
i've just found at a club
if i'm beating you i gotta know your ass
let me
i'm glad you just did it so a little
little little wine and dying get to know
him a little bit
no no no no no no no no no no i ain't
never taken a go on a date in my
lifetime i've been i've been to nando's
tell a lie actually i've been on i've
been i've been to nando's once
and um i've been to some
some little bar in london once with like
a girl that i was seeing
but even that it's like drinks don't
know it's not known but most of the time
i'll just go out or bring you to the
crib once i
know that i can't do that now obviously
because yeah
i was gonna that was gonna be my that
was gonna be a question like what's your
mom's uh what's your mom saying all it
is
my mom's cool you know like i got a cool
mom like when i when i even when i was
in school
that she lit up my matron or everyone's
in trouble even when i was in trouble in
school like she might back it and then
she told me off in private but
in front of people she'll back me in it
yeah but yeah yeah she's all right
so obviously she knows she can't stop me
from being me
and if girls happen to want to come see
me and then the guys can come see
me i don't know if you saw this or not
but mia khalifa
who obviously
you know what's going already
my brother called me like [__] mad
i'll check her in stop my bum i hold a
brother in it
yeah i've seen it i've seen it i've seen
it amazing so obviously
she was dying so long to your to your
verse and um
will there ever be a a video
collaboration and not that kind of video
so no one no dirty minded people out
there not that kind of video
but would you ever do something with
that i'll definitely do something with
her
um you know
you know what i'll give you that one gem
i'll drop myself in it once and then
when she when she posted it i was very
positive on my story
and um i replied didn't it and i was
like what you want to roll with a geezer
in the uk and she was like now
i've got it on my phone somewhere in it
she was like no i'm married and i start
all right pick up big up for the ticket
talk anyway let me go for some
if she was on it i'd definitely be on it
obviously she's it was she america isn't
it she live in america yeah
i think she's she's out in america yeah
there's really like i think she's a west
ham found which is
a bit bizarre yeah that's crazy isn't it
she supports a lot of the uk stuff
actually i see i think that she
supported her
that's his um tune as well so yeah
she and she replied straight she's cool
so she bothers his eyes every really and
truly if you're between that
maybe if like you're a bit younger i'd
say if you're like 14 39 maybe you might
not know we're in it because she stopped
all of that a long time ago and she
actually does a lot of things for
women and female empowerment and whatnot
but um yeah above anyone between the
ages of like
my age to maybe 15 and to about 30.
that's like every
little boy's dream in it like are you
mad mia khalifa
we've got letter let's not lie now lads
we've all watched a video of me
in it let's all be real i know you have
bob i definitely have
let me listen listen my girlfriend's in
another room no comment bro no comment
no comments say no more
we'll leave it at that we'll chat after
we chat
[Laughter]
so big shout out to haruki designs who
made this incredible art for you
like would you ever like if they
approached you saying look we want to do
only fool's horse's remake
do you reckon like you'd be on it are
you mad yeah what dale boy
are you crazy million percent definitely
bob i like attention and i like
spotlight so you ain't just music that
i'm trying to get into as long as the
spotlight's on me and everyone's
watching and i've got a whole lot of
attention
do acting and do dancing entertainment
the whole shebang uh thank you very much
uh you've been incredible and uh
i'm loving it as a brighton boy myself
you're you're smashing it and you're
breaking let me see you said gang i'll
stick together
stick together come on bro now amazing
legend then thank you very much man that
was it alright cool appreciate you
in a bit